Top interview tip is do your research.
There's nothing worse
than when I've been interviewing candidates
where they've come to the interview
and made a major boo-boo,
which just told me that they hadn't done any research.
And I'm probably a stickler for research
because as a former journalist,
it's something that's kind of core
to what your whole career is about.
So, yeah, do your research,
and I think from that you'll find confidence
will come quite easily within the interview
because you're prepared.
So, yeah, be prepared,
do your research,
and confidence will be the outcome of that.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.